eyes are popping off then there we go
okay
so
uh
500 mils always mix up he's got he's
running he's changing names every week
so 500 mils of trend dropping the lars
that is his true main for the past year
or so
performing really well with him and
extroverts going full on with his uh
xiaoyu which is like his strongest pick
by far
all right yeah we getting a lot of
character variety so far i guess the
shoulder the clothes oh yeah
we got it all
oh what a whip punish
beautiful
okay
back turn low
running three uses the aop
i love the downforce coming from lars
but down back four as well make sure you
use those lows to keep laying on it
because she can definitely start to get
annoying if you let that back turn
stands rock you let aop rock those lows
are going to be your only the only way
to stop what a whip punisher again
very nice wall but no
nice wall splat that should finish it
once he gets the yeah oh no
there it is it's that five hp man it
makes the difference it's the whole
radical bro everybody got to eat
it was like check your life bottom line
you're gonna have an extra five points
you mean i can live with that wall break
combo yes it's because came that's right
that's kind of lucky to worry about
right so now you guys got to thank
harada you know there's some people out
there gonna be like hey harada i don't
like the fact that i got a deal with
five hp well you gotta deal with it
oh there you go shoe shine back one just
the contest
with the wall
saving lives once again there we go big
pressure gets the low oh wow
and then the laser the little bit still
gets the hit extra man has a chance now
we're still in his first game
shooting star
the running three
wow
get off of me it's my new dress i don't
want you to touch me down back forward
just the tail end of it the myla address
i like these pokes extra man is starting
to go to instead of committing to some
of these bigger moves
oh my god that pressure arc blast good
punish excrement
quick cancel on the stance shooting star
to steal the round excrement you've been
extra man
extra mitch have been extra man
oh
okay
oh let me get the wall yo don't do it
don't do it don't take bro oh that was
dangerous
oh boy
okay we're good we're good
attrition right now it's anyone's game
no okay went for the grab that's pretty
common
oh my god what a check
wow
yeah i thought that he would he would
roll out from the wall splat but he
caught him right there for the last hit
so yeah extra man taking the first match
right now
looking pretty tough for 500.
fighting it yeah it's just nice
fighting it i really do like this uh
extra man with the lane just really
going back and forth there was never a
time where you saw 500 literally just
stay with that lead even if the pokes
were really strong where the lows were
really switching up and trying to find
the opening yeah really didn't break the
focus of extra man and that's really
what you want to do with link if you can
get it lean to be aggressive and you can
just make your opponent hesitate even
slightly it comes out in ling's favor uh
we saw a back turn duck with aop to get
under the ark blast like are you serious
like i would have been yeah that was
mentally distraught he plowed a blank
bro
yeah yeah yeah she just ducked my arm
back turned like i would have been tight
like
yeah yeah yeah that that hurt i saw that
i was like man
i'm glad i'm i didn't like input that
arc blast man
i wouldn't want that to be in my hands
right now that was pretty tough
i legit just would have been staring in
this i would just been lo i'm like for
real
bad dynamco please oh
in the gym interesting choice okay
i wonder what the thought process behind
that was for the shape of the stage yeah
it's a pretty decent station when it
comes to calculating your your sense of
wars basement so that's pretty decent
look at that i just realized that he's
got an 11 win streak on his goddamn
account
what are you trying to impose with him
no that's what you're supposed to do if
you come into a tournament you just got
to get the longest win streak get like a
50-game win streak and then come into
the tournament and you're like man am i
going to be able to stop this guy like
there you go
i like them dancing a little bit here
or goes for the hop kick tries to go for
the aop roll but didn't work out get the
boost up from back turn no block on the
low this time gonna get really close to
the wall
back turn lower
using the ankles and the shooting start
again
oh wow and just because they actually
dropped the combo but extra man actually
got the wow wait a minute
there we go picks him out of the air
they can get the wall here
goes for the shoe shine no good gets the
grab no break very nice
bolt and razor
i like the knowledge
ah shoulder
good punish
goes in the raw aop gets the counter
here
look at this guy okay okay
okay
okay
oh
okay still on the board for extra mint
okay shuts him up
oh okay we got those two lars got those
two i was wondering when we're gonna
start seeing them
if i would have saw if you could have
ducked my my arc blast back time i
literally would have started doing orbit
instantly i'm like oh word we're going
to orbit them oh nice kind of counter
hit on the board on the board there he
is okay this is his chance to get an
official one point
let's see
i like the change up in pace here
500 taking the time
nice little punish
okay oh doesn't get away punish on that
kind of tough it's scary to get in there
even though you see the opportunity
sometimes not worth the risk
there we go you baiting out the orbital
takes the mid option
patience on both sides here
yeah yeah yeah
lively yeah we're like half with 30
seconds in and it's pretty big life
oh he doesn't get leads
chance
needs this round absolutely needs this
round this is winner's side so still has
a chance on the loser's side but you
don't even want to go that far
down back four yeah dirty okay great job
ten seconds just about left on the clock
movement going into overtime for extra
man
oh my god that could have been big okay
this is the longer he sees that and it
denies it but it is
wow that felt sloppy man oh like i
imagine like these guys like their hands
are trembling on trying to get it right
it could have ended right but it didn't
and i was like oh my god okay
500 mil staying alive
another chance a redemption let's see
let's see this is a tough match dude
these have been like two games already
and it's been to the wire all of them i
like this i like this i don't like the
block i like the slug
yes yes yes
it's like some [ __ ] minority stuff you
know what i'm saying but they just like
beat that crap out of each other it's
like this you say in the real world that
that would have stopped like 20 minutes
ago but they're still going dude look
that's why digital violence is okay in
my book bro you can beat the crap out of
each other in video games bro and then
you just go back yeah select screen and
do it all over again there's nothing
wrong with violence bro
yeah yeah
let's see what choices they've made i
think extra mint will probably keep the
xiaohu is the strongest pick let's see
if he picks a state oh jungle outpost
yep that's a good choice he does he does
fall back to this stage a lot
well it sets tired on winning inside
right now
look at the the tours we get of these
stages i'm telling you right yeah this
is they started doing this i started
figuring out other stuff all over the
stage
i'm like well i didn't even know it was
something back there to look at
extra
let's see if there's a combo there is
none
yeah i was like we're gonna get a wall
break now
later later there it is standing pool
okay push and pull trying to bait out
something out of him
i love i love the bait beautifully
the aop the in and out and what a back
turn
kick gets the wall bounce and the route
extraman drawn first blood in this last
game
and by blood i mean
bubble
nice tail sweep
yeah
okay
keeping that mid pressure
and look how much
look how much slower
i said though
oh my god
oh nice gets the hard knock down four
four four
okay extra min doing a lot of push and
pull coming in and out trying to
overextend uh 500 mils 500 500 mills
feeling the pressure he needs like to
end this so he has to like take more
risks
putting himself in a bad position but
he's getting some damage in there but
look man
down four once all the orb
cares bro that was the five hp
that's right that was a little steamy
there but not enough
damn look at that picking him yeah
that's a hp stimmy
counter hit down back four
yo 500 okay on a rampage right now oh no
break on the oneplus 2 though oh i'm
gonna big damage oh no what how did you
get out of all
wow okay
keeping it cool don't make too many big
risks oh so there's a way to throw again
trying to get those orbitals to work for
him but they're not doing much oh
there's another one
oh there it is wow if that's the wall
you could be dead
this could you might be dead oh still
alive
oh let's go standing
there oh my god like jumping around dude
this is insane we're still in there okay
extra mint still match point
count back four
500 turning up the offense a little bit
here
oh wow there it isn't good
hey
starting starting to do a lot
again
blocks the down back four standing one
almost crosstalk big pounce
sidewalk guess the wall splash
again he's gonna be versing yagami this
is very interesting man
oh boy like let me check like excrement
yeah he was the winner of